you said earlier
you like to call a spade a spade so why
why did you feel the need to to call
out the way you did because like for
instance right i look at six nine and
i'm like okay
you this you violated did this did that
right that's it
right i'm not pressing who's promoting
six nine i'm not
pressing academics it's all you know
popping up on clubhouse and [ __ ] like
you know cuz of [ __ ] like you
you know supporting this this this you
need to be in all this so they
definitely pressed them i'm not doing
i'm not doing all that right
okay you asked me your dude violated
some of them people are my comrades
that's in jail you know what i'm saying
shout out to nuke that you know
some of them do just is i know
personally
but i'm never it's never came out of my
mouth that it's on
when we catch your [ __ ] ass is
what it's gonna be right i hate to say
it
69 made history again because
the prey pulled up on the predator and
that's unheard of
see usually the predator controls the
narrative because he can talk that [ __ ]
and deep down inside he know he ain't
gonna do nothing right so what he does
is if he know his prey is over there he
just don't go over there
he stays away from him so it's never a
situation
in this situation the prey pulled up on
the predator
and how that's supposed to work once you
didn't set the stage
and say it's home you're going to dress
a [ __ ] when they see you when
they pull up on you
right they bro with sick skinheads they
pulled up on being called me
and you [ __ ] laid them out i could
have said always six of them
and i stayed in the car i got on you
know what a lot of people would have
said
oh what do y'all expect it's six i'm
gonna see the rules
and code of the streets where i come
from whether
it's in favor or not in favor you got to
handle your business
win lose a draw it's been a situation
where it's more of us than them
it been situation where it's even steven
it's been situation was
it's me by myself i have to remain who
i'm supposed to be
so on the flip side when that man pulled
up
with his squad and let's let's for the
note
little dude ain't no house arrest no
more there's no police with that dude
i know a few of them dudes they're not
police right and you in florida
they stand your ground stand your ground
in fact we all know about that right
so at the end of the day the whole
situation people are saying oh me going
to go to jail hey look check this out
if you are worried about it concerning
yourself with
jail or or or in the backlash of it
then don't speak on it don't involve
yourself to that capacity
to where you pressing this dude and
pressing people around this dude
say the dudes are right i don't agree
with the [ __ ] he did and keep it moving
but you set the stage to where it's on
when meek and gang was going at it right
when we bump it's home
they say yo y'all can't do that show in
philly uh we be there at seven o'clock
two bus loads deep five run the cars
deep it's gonna be whatever it's gonna
be
and we went and had a cheese stick
afterwards we see you it's sown
ain't no talking ain't none of that this
is the irrational rules we live by
right so you can't oh okay today and a
good day because i might get caught
nah [ __ ] this is what this is
you you you charlie saying if you sign
up for this yeah you got to take what
come with that okay now
look it's here his squad pull up it
ain't no talking
get off that's it that's how they go
if you got a squad with you they ain't
gonna move with you then maybe
you know other people change that up
because they had no problem
doing that to suffocate off on safari
they chased that man down like a dog
and he ain't dead no instagram [ __ ] he
ain't saying [ __ ]
he called you no [ __ ] he ain't called
you nothing you know [ __ ]
you took his woman why are you mad at
him
you know what i'm saying so you had no
problem you know you can't be
i call it selective politicking you want
to pick and choose when you want to do
this to do this and do that
nah